what's it like working with kiss
just in general having him as your big
homie man
it's dope man it's like like the kiss
that people saw on verses i see that
every day facts yeah people think like
did he
i don't know like that that's some new
[ __ ] for him no that's how he acts on
his block with like 100 homies around
100 the way he cracks jokes and all of
that like and then like yeah he he um
he's just for the culture man like he
he's a real rapper bro at the core and
are you are you signing his label yeah
i'm down with kiss since i i've been
down with kiss for a minute yeah but
like officially like 2017.
yeah it's crazy because i feel like that
versus moment
like you said it kind of like reminded a
lot of people like yo kisses they don't
say top five dead or alive and for no
reason you know what i'm saying just to
burn any
rapper his age right now oh 100 no i
mean any rapper i mean i right now give
any rapper and i got the utmost respect
the utmost respect
for whole
nas
am
kiss will give each one of them a 16 on
the same beat kiss will burn them i can
agree with you there that's a fact for
sure i think too cove might
stand a chance now just just in that bar
for him like it's not that wouldn't be
bothered about 16 16 16 bars with the
goats with all of the goats these are
the goats that's why i'm you know
talking about them but kisses burning
[ __ ]